where's the headline I want to see in
the Los Angeles Times tomorrow Los
Angeles the Koch brothers hi I'm Zach
why smaller for a reason TV we're here
in downtown Los Angeles where people are
gathered to protest the potential buyout
of the Los Angeles Times and other
Tribune companies by the Koch brothers
we want the LA Times to you know sell
independently so that we can keep
journalism real and fair and not totally
run by the coach yeah why specifically
the cokes well there are the record
speaks for themselves they have a very
conservative agenda we are at a point in
our history where we need to be a little
bit more open-minded a little bit more
liberal on views all across the board
Cope's self-described as libertarian and
they fund a lot of groups that are
against the drug war the LA Times came
out against prop 19 which would legalize
marijuana in LA and they've pushed anti
dispensary measures are you right in
some sense they would push the LA Times
to the left on those kind of issues um I
believe that regardless of their views
it's not what the general populace means
the one thing that is so amazing about
democracy is the fact that we don't
always have to have the same opinions
but we will fight to the death to have
everybody be able to say their opinions
what about the Koch brothers opinions
there's the difference between yellow
journalism for only one side is told or
there's the difference between being
able to express your opinions and having
somebody else be able to rebut on stage
you actually said Koch brothers should
drop dead is that a little over the top
well I you know there was a there's an
old New York Post or maybe was daily
news headline in the 70s when the city
was going bankrupt and the headline was
forged a city drop dead and so I was
trying to give a little bit of a
newspaper historical headline and my
speed the LA City Council has made a
proposal to possibly take money out of
invest in the LA Times if this sale goes
through to the Koch brothers do you
think it's appropriate for the city
government to get involved in a private
sale like this I think that the Los
Angeles Times is a special institution
that is of significant importance to the
entire city into the region Los Angeles
Times is our paper of record if the
cokes do by the LA Times what will you
do will you keep reading it no I will
cancel my subscription I've been a
subscriber for 25 years my parents
subscribe for almost 60 years we would
all be carefully to our subscription so
you'll read a different paper there are
other newspapers in the region that are
stepping up their game perhaps an
anticipation of those the beauty of
competition right yeah but I don't know
its beauty and parents too if you
disagree with them why does that mean
that they shouldn't feel to buy a
newspaper well I feel like they
shouldn't be able to have a monopoly
their aim is to actually monopolize on
media and I believe freedom of press and
being able to have like a is it a
monopoly though if there's there's other
newspapers in Los Angeles there aren't
other newspapers but what is the one
person newspaper that most people know
LA Weekly la time oh I always time
hahaha do you read the other times I do
did you read it today i have not this
morning because i had to get back out
here for do you read the only times yes
I do uh did you read it today not today
did you read the LA Times today yes I
did well what what story had the most
impact for you today I can't even
remember aside there's a couple other
billionaires like Eli Broad who has lots
of real estate developments in downtown
Los Angeles do other purchasers concern
you in the way that the Koch brothers do
we've always supported the idea that
paper should be owned locally if
possible that they should right now the
LA Times is owned by the Tribune Company
which is not local and they shouldn't be
owned as part of a large conglomerate
who should be allowed to buy the LA
Times um well like I said I think it
should be split up
like the Tribune shouldn't be selling
all seven at once honestly I wouldn't
mind anybody buying it if it was sold
that way although I wouldn't want the
cokes to have it that's for sure
you